[Music]
in back in my day news submitted by Joe
Molly and DMV oh there's more efficient
a writer has researched why people
disliked new music as they get older
oh hi can I take can I tell you what my
theory is okay so here it is when you're
young you're bored as [ __ ] cuz you ain't
got many things going for you so you
need energy you need excitement right
the older you are you got too many
things going on for you that you just
want to get away from [ __ ] so you want
more relaxing things you just super
stressed out and you're just like I want
to chill oh all right well just because
for me I still like I like new the new
hype stuff that's good
but then there is a part of me like a
lot of the new stuff on me I don't I
don't I just don't relate or I don't
know what it is and I become evil way
before my time now like I'm listening to
like Ella Fitzgerald I'm just like Chile
yeah I'm like what the [ __ ] is my gift
type of bats to Frank Sinatra stuff like
yeah it's like so weird he likes it but
that's the old [ __ ] I've been like an
ass [ __ ] and then uh me goes drop the
album my feeling last month or some [ __ ]
and I was okay I gotta be hip to the
cool and understand some new [ __ ] I
download the album and the whole time I
was listening to I want to kill myself
I'm like this [ __ ] sucks ass I can't
believe people like it yeah sorry
there's a reason why you don't like it I
like idiot oh let me know the detail but
you like old EDM not the new [ __ ] right
like what's the [ __ ] difference
additional idiot right the classic with
the horns yeah it's like when I it's
like when I listen to this this the the
Spanish radio station whenever the
Mexican radio station yeah it's all the
same music right like over and over over
again
it's polka polka right it is with my
accordion the [ __ ] trumpet you know
that's where it came from is it right
yeah yeah cuz the Germans came to Texas
you know there was a lot of Mexicans in
Texas and then they'd learn from each
other and then they brought it back to
Mexico that's why the beat is polka
right after this author he looked into
why people don't like the music as you
get older and so what we found out here
is that the
it shows that the average man's musical
taste is developed between the ages of
13 and 16 while a woman takes shape
between the ages of 11 and 14 so we are
more prone to like the music that came
out during that timeframe in our lives
rather than anything else because that's
the time when any little thing that
happens in your life like you make an
emotional connection to the songs that
you listen to especially during that
developmental stage I'm [ __ ] then that
means any song without gunshots I'm not
gonna like all the songs have to have
gunshots it S&C that you know what that
really explains a lot because I like a
lot of hip-hop that talks about like
violence and like Street [ __ ] but every
time I hear like this like [ __ ]
[ __ ] hip-hop about your emotions and
feeling like the [ __ ] out of here I want
somebody dead in this next story tellers
like oh yeah that's because at that time
when you guys were that age those are
the music that's about the music that
was popular in that time I like Justin
Bieber though and it doesn't mean you
can't like it it's just the fact that
you're just more but you also see you
like Justin Bieber but you also don't
like all of Justin Bieber's album too
per se you like specific Justin Bieber
songs that sound like 90s hits yeah you
like the baby song yeah who doesn't like
the baby song I love watch my part of it
thank goodness for Napster I explored so
much music from downloading illegal
songs
me too but I always get the titles wrong
because I always downloaded illegally so
I always thought like a different band
did it oh yeah yeah yeah and then three
days later you realize you're [ __ ] up
not even his mom or three years man like
I'm not somewhere at a trivia night and
I'm like I swear to God like this is my
Ghostface Killah and they're like no
it's not a [ __ ] kidding me like that
stupid should I've ever heard poor whiny
voice - no with the same group because
all of the mp3s are mislabeled like oh
yeah so I thought I swear was by boy
Stinnett past true [ __ ] all my files
no knowing this - it's kind of cool I
guess doesn't explain anything it's just
saying that your tastes are developed
from that time by it's something you're
more inclined to be connected to that
music from that era from when or
whatever music you listen to from that
time in your
so explain Adele to me then how does
that how does that work cuz I didn't
hear no Adele when I was 11 to frickin
14 and now I [ __ ] worship Adele okay
that sounded it wasn't there yeah I
don't know if you're telling the truth
anymore I [ __ ] love Adele okay no I
don't have to do so Viva Nikki though I
like R&B and soul from that old-school
era and I found it during that time and
I'm so glad of which which one what
stuff when I was 13 or 16
yeah like Al Green old school Oh Jays
that's true I felt like soap mold is so
black seven to fourteen fifth grade to
eighth grade about that's why I like
that song
that [ __ ] on blue song see if I heard
that song object this mother [ __ ]
annoying [ __ ]
but now I like I like that that's what I
thought when I first heard it back in
the day right I heard that song recently
at a taco shop
oh [ __ ] for some reason the [ __ ] the
the the mp3 player that they had was not
working because they usually played the
[ __ ] spat you know the mariachi music
but they had that bullshit-ass song I
was pissed off would you rather be
listening to that all day or the Barbie
song I'm a Barbie girl I'm down with all
of it they are the same song is it one
day I'm gonna hear David tell a happy
story
oh I refuse your [ __ ] angry I was so
disturbed
I specifically go to that taco stand for
the authentic Mexican experience so you
wanted here mariachi yeah I want to hear
mariachi music and I want to eat is such
a LuPone piece god damn he's like tacos
ball boys like god damn it
I guess is part the experience I
expected this I go I went there at that
time probably three times a week that's
funny I remember when songs came out
like in high school I hated them I'm
like [ __ ] this mainstream [ __ ] but now
when I hear it I'm like oh hell yeah
does that juvenile looking NASA man
enjoy yeah yeah I look back and I'm like
this song's dope but I do remember I
[ __ ] hated that it's weird though
that pop [ __ ] felt like I didn't realize
how integrated it isn't to my brain
because like like Nelly Nelly was like
he's not really like hip-hop hip-hop you
know in my personal opinion however if I
if you go through his whole [ __ ]
discography I know like 12 songs and I
don't know why it's just in my [ __ ]
head I have a specific playlist on
Spotify called crunk Liddy I wonder if
the thong song comes on all these like
songs that I thought was at the time
[ __ ] stupid and mainstream but why do
I know every [ __ ] there I can't wait
to see what I'm one day I'm driving and
I see it I'll be I'll be old probably
too and I look over and I see a grandpa
and he's playing like baby music that'll
be great
you know what's nuts I was in Hollywood
the other day and on the bus stop
I saw a rich [ __ ] or now rich Brian's
face all over it oh he's huge you just
chopped it all the way he told me I'm
the favorite guy on JK so that's pretty
awesome his number don't need it
God is DMS I don't get guys numbers
that's that's I don't do it I don't do
all that did you buy it well you got his
number yeah what did you get his number
do you have is no but why why would you
get his number though uh because we're
friends like that we're like this do you
know about this Bart
are you okay with this she has parts
like big date courts like they go hang
out she showed me when he got it she
[ __ ] him you don't have this number
because we're not that tight and I can
go through her yeah Bart's like big they
hang out they go get dinners it's great
I love it I give the baby a bath a
couple times about his album though it's
a great item individually we bought the
album oh really
that's awesome I downloaded it for free
that's why you don't give us well no I
mean like I don't really listen to music
so it's okay yeah yeah everything that
you say detaches you for
I play my own music come on man
literally lives in his own world
like last week he was doing something he
was doing something right and she was
like yep
like what are you doing oh I was
picturing the words and when I tapped
the word it exploded yeah look at us
like we were crazy did you not just hear
his invitation he's like yeah you guys
can can come over in my house he's like
you guys can swim in my pool and just
smell like chlorine get covered in smell
like chlorine that was his pitch like
that happened off camera but you guys
can't come over if you need a chlorine
bath wait are you telling me that you
guys don't have music flowing through
your like head drums oh yeah you do
right so why do you need the radio
because that's life I said that year you
can't hear like the whole song like from
start to end
yeah so then that means right now you
know what song is playing but I'm gonna
be poppin up oh I'm the scatman you know
that song yeah you know that song that
song don't pull it up it's dull and
sometimes the real thing is better than
what playing your mind really yeah I
agree
you don't think so you don't think like
let's say you're listening to a song
yeah the song version is probably better
than your head and then the concert is
even better than that you know I believe
you can't remix the song in your head
better oh you know but I also listened
to it - and you were [ __ ] sucks though
lately a lot of these new artists
because like technology is so great with
like Melodyne and like auto-tune I
[ __ ] hate like I've gone to a couple
recently where the the live performance
they [ __ ] suck yeah they cannot sing
to save their [ __ ] life like what the
[ __ ] is going on like for example like
scissor right
I [ __ ] love scissors track it's dope
is fun number one I don't think her
voice is that unique in the first place
I think anybody could fill a role
however I went to her whose scissor
this is the lady with the good awake the
covers are ice no that's the
your [ __ ] little dad 13s I have a kid
and then you lose like half of your
references 13 at 17
yeah but they are [ __ ] off-key
they're flat you can perform they're
like yeah they're like tone death and
[ __ ] and then I was like okay maybe this
was a bad performance so I went on like
AOL live you know where they had those
like that
there's still [ __ ] off-key it's like
you can't [ __ ] sing but how is this
possible your R&B artists just in case
you guys weren't sure that I'm white me
and Nicki went to a Regina Spektor
concert recently
exactly exactly super very very white
folksy singer like Norah Jones oh yeah
exactly
I love Norah Jones right so French but
she's a pop version of what she does so
we were there and and she's doing this
[ __ ] and this just shows you know how
would an unreasonable old man I am like
stuck between songs she was like you
know just real quick I just want to say
like I love Wales and we need to like
save them and help them and I'm just
like Oh for [ __ ] sake saying [ __ ]
about Wales
I'm like when I thought I liked Wales I
shut the [ __ ] up and just [ __ ] sing
the song I need your whale [ __ ] talk
I didn't pay for a lecture [ __ ] exactly
[Music]